♪ ♪
>> Dana: ELIZABETH WARREN
THING A SURGE OF THE POLLS BUT
AN OLD CONTROVERSY CONTINUES TO
HAUNT HER.
THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC HOPEFUL
APOLOGIZING AGAIN FOR TWO
NATIVE AMERICANS FOR HER
PREVIOUS CLAIMS.
>> I KNOW THAT I'VE MADE
MISTAKES.
I AM SORRY FOR HARM I HAVE
CAUSED.
I HAVE LISTENED AND I HAVE
LEARNED A LOT, AND I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE MANY CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD TOGETHER.
IT IS A GREAT HONOR TO BE ABLE
TO PARTNER WITH INDIAN COUNTRY,
AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE TRIED TO DO
AS A SENATOR, AND THAT'S WHAT I
PROMISE I WILL DO AS PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: THAT WAS HER TODAY AT
A BIG EVENT, JESSE.
A CONTRARY COULD BE THIS SPEAKS
TO THE STRENGTH OF HER CAMPAIGN
THAT SHE WENT TO THIS EVENT
KNOWING THAT SHE WOULD HAVE TO
DO THIS.
SHE COULD'VE HAD A SCHEDULING
CONFLICT, ONE OF THOSE
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS, LIKE A
DENTIST APPOINTMENT YOU CAN'T
CHANGE.
>> Jesse: I THINK IT WAS A
WHITE WATCH.
-- WHITEWASH.
THE MODERATOR ENDORSED HER, ON
THE EVE OF THE EVENT, SHE
SCRUBBED THE VIDEO WHERE SHE
RELEASED HER AND DNA RESULTS
FROM HER CAMPAIGN WEBSITE.
SHE HAS TERRIBLE POLITICAL
INSTINCTS AND SHE'S A PHONY.
WHAT SHE DID TO NATIVE AMERICANS
WAS SOME PEOPLE SAY IT'S WORSE
THAN WHAT PROMPTED TO
MINORITIES.
SHE STOLE THEIR IDENTITY AND
THEN SHE USE THAT FAKE IDENTITY
TO SUPPRESS THE MINORITIES'
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION,
JOBS.
THEN SHE PROFITED FROM THE FAKE
IDENTITY.
WHEN SHE GOT BUSTED ON IT WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP MOCKED HER, SHE
SAID IT'S AN ETHNIC SLUR,
POCAHONTAS.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS SHE'S UP
IN THE POLLS BECAUSE SHE'S
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  B
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  O
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  S
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  B
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  H
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  N
GETTING SOME BERNIE BURROUGHS  D
HER.
BLACK AMERICANS DON'T LOVE HER
THAT MUCH.
WALL STREET HATES HER.
IT'S ANOTHER LANDSLIDE VICTORY
FOR THE PRESIDENT IF SHE GETS
THE NOMINATION.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT SAID AT
THE RALLY THE OTHER NIGHT THAT
HE HIT HER HARD ON THE ISSUE BUT
NOW SHE'S COMING BACK AND SHE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN.
BECAUSE IT'S SO COMPETITIVE ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, WHAT YOU
THINK NONE OF THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS GO AFTER HER ABOUT IT?
>> Greg: I WILL TELL YOU, AS A
BLACK LESBIAN, I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR HER TO REACH OUT.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
WHAT IS SHE APOLOGIZING FOR?
I'M NOT SURE.
THAT AMAZING VIDEO THAT YOU
MENTIONED SCRUBBED VINDICATED
HER.
SHE WAS 1/17000 NATIVE AMERICAN.
SHE PLEADED UP.
SHE APOLOGIZING FOR PERPETUATING
THE LIE?
IS SHE APOLOGIZING FOR THE
IMPERSONATION?
THE EXAGGERATION, THE
EXPLOITATION?
REMEMBER, SHE USED IT TO GET
AHEAD IN THE LAW SCHOOL USED HER
LINE TO GET AHEAD BY SAYING THAT
WE HAVE THE FIRST FEMALE
MINORITY LAWYER.
HARVARD, I BELIEVE?
THAT'S WHY I DON'T GIVE ANYMORE
MIND TO THAT SCHOOL.
ANYWAY, LIKE JESSE SAID, THE
MEDIA CALLING HER -- PAINTING I
IT, IT'S LIKE CALLING A DUMB
PERSON EINSTEIN.
I THINK I'M CONFUSED, AS YOU CAN
TELL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S
APOLOGIZING FOR.
EE IS SHE ADMITTING SHE LIED?
SHE SAID SHE'S NATIVE AMERICAN.
>> Dana: IN A PIECE LAST WEEK,
IT WAS A STORY ABOUT HER POLL
NUMBERS THAT THEN THEY
INTERVIEWED SOMEBODY WHO'D GONE
TO ONE OF HER EVENTS AND THEY
SAID SHE'S SO SMART.
SHE REALLY HAS A PLAN.
THE LAST LINE WAS, IT'S THE
POCAHONTAS THING.
THAT WAS HOW HE ENDED IT.
IS IT ON THE MINDS IN REGARDS TO
ELECTABILITY AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE
REALIZE THIS WHAT TOPAZ WHEN HE
COMES AT ELIZABETH WARREN.
THAT'S WHY HE'S ATTACKING HER.
SHE'S RISING IN THE POLLS, HE
WAS AFTER SLEEPY JOE, JOE BIDEN,
HE'S REALLY ON HIS MIND AND HE'S
THE MOST ATTACKED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW SHE'S BACK IN THE PICTURE
AND AGAIN BECAUSE SHE'S A STRONG
CANDIDATE AND A RISING CAT
EVENT, SHE HAS MOMENTUM.
THE FACT THAT SHE WENT TO THIS
FORUM, SHE WAS INVITED TO THIS
FORUM, IT INDICATES IN THE MAN'S
OF THE WORD -- THE WORD OF ON
THE MAN WHO HOSTED IT, THEY
DON'T THINK IT'S A BIG DEAL.
WHAT YOU GET IS A SITUATION, SHE
HAS BIG IDEAS, POLICY IDEAS SO
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS THEY SAY
THIS POCAHONTAS THING IS TRUMP'S
AGENDA.
IT'S THE WAY HE PUTS PEOPLE
DOWN.
IT'S TRIVIAL TO US.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO HER,
ELIZABETH WARREN'S TOP ISSUES.
HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION, HELPING
YOUNG PEOPLE GET AHEAD, PAY FOR
THE BIG TUITION DEBT AND SAYING
TO THE RICH PEOPLE, NO MORE
PROTECTIONS.
NO MORE TOO BIG TO FAIL.
PEOPLE ARE REACTING TO HER AS A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE, INCLUDING
NATIVE AMERICANS.
>> Dana: HILLARY CLINTON NEVER
APOLOGIZED FOR THE EMAIL
SCANDAL.
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS APOLOGIZED
A FEW TIMES FOR THIS.
EVEN THOUGH PEOPLE AREN'T SURE.
>> Katie: SHE HAS NEVER
ADMITTED SHE'S NOT
NATIVE AMERICAN.
SHE'S NEVER SAID SHE'S NOT
CHEROKEE.
SHE HAS PARSED THIS LINE BETWEEN
I'VE CAUSED PAIN, SORRY FOR
THAT, BUT SHE'S NEVER SAID I'M
SORRY FOR USING THE 1/1000 MAY
BE ARGUMENT TO PUT ON THE BAR
CARD IN TEXAS THAT I WAS
NATIVE AMERICAN ORDER TO GET
THAT FIRST STATUS IS THE FIRST
WOMAN OF COLOR AND HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL.
I'M NOT CLEAR ON WHAT SHE'S
APOLOGIZING FOR EITHER.
I THINK IF SHE'D NOT GONE TO THE
FORUM, IT PROBABLY LITTLE --
WOULD'VE LOOKED WORSE.
>> Dana: MIGHT IT BE A SIGN OF
STRENGTH FOR HER THAT SHE WENT?
>> Jesse: AND OTHER
NATIVE AMERICAN NEWS,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DID A POLL
AND ASKED WHAT WAS THE NUMBER
ONE EMOTION HE FELT WHEN YOU SAW
THE WASHINGTON REDSKIN MASCOT
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE TOP ONE
WAS?
PRIDE.
THEY LIKE IT.
>> Juan: DO YOU KNOW MY NUMBER
ONE REACTION?
>> Jesse: THE EAGLES ARE GOING
TO BEAT THEM TWICE.
>> Juan: THAT'S MY TEAM.
I JUST DON'T LIKE THAT NAME.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU THINK I
FEEL ABOUT THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS?
I AM A BELOW AVERAGE HEIGHT
PERSON.
MY FAVORITE BASEBALL TEAM AS THE
GIANTS.
EVERYDAY I WAKE UP AND I GO I
HAVE TO ROOT FOR A TEAM THAT
TOWERS OVER MY DIMINUTIVE
STAMPED OR.
>> Dana: THAT YOU COULD NEVER